would you be cool if a guy that makes  less money but he's very he's a hard  worker like he's ambitious  yeah okay so like if he was making like  let's say he just started his own  business but he makes 45 000 a year  would you date him  you wouldn't be able to afford my  engagement ring I'm getting an eight  carat cushion cut vintage engagement  ring if you make forty five thousand  dollars a year it would take what  four years no eight years how much I  don't know anything about Rings how much  how much is that about two hundred  thousand dollars girl you want a 200 000  are you insane  my ring has to Sparkle from across the  street it's gonna blind people